همم
يجد الاباء المرهقون في الصين صعوبات جمه
في التوفيق بين العمل ورعايه الاطفال
وينحون باللائمه في ذلك على مجتمع باهظ
التكلفه وتنافسي للغايه وقله المساعده من
الدوله ويقولون ان ذلك هو ربما احد
الاسباب الرئيسيه وراء انخفاض معدل
المواليد في البلاد
عن مقدار الدعم الذي تقدمه الحكومه
للامهات او العائلات فان الاتجاه المتمثله
في انجاب عدد اقل من الاطفال امر لا مفر
منه اعتقد ان هذا تنظيم طبيعي للبشره كلما
انجبنا اكثر ولا استعدادنا للقيام بذلك
لاول مره منذ وقود اصبح عدد سكان الصين
اقل من ما كان عليه في بدايه العام الماضي
وافاد المكتب الوطني للاحصاء بان البلاد
كان لديها 800,000 شخص اقل في نهايه عام
120 مقارنه بعام 2021
ومما يزيد الامر تعقيدا ان عدد الوفيات
فاقى عدد المواليد في العام الماضي نبه
بعض الاقتصاديين الى ان معدل المواليد
المنخفض وشيخوخه السريعه لسكان قد يكون
لهما اثار بعيده المدى لسماحليا فحسب ولكن
على الاقتصاد العالمي في حين يرى بعض اخر
انخفاض عدد السكان لا يتوقع ان يؤدي
بالضروره الى ضعف الاقتصاد
لن يغيره هذا الامر الوضع الاقتصاديه في
الصين ولم يغير الاوضاع الاقتصاديه او
الجيو السياسيه النسبيه هذه الصين لكن من
الواضح انها قضيه النفسيه كبيره وربما
تكون اكبرها واهمها تتعلق بكيفيه تعامل
الصين مع هذه التغييرات في النموذج
الديمغرافي الجديد للتراجع السكاني او
النمو السلبي
ساعه الصيني الى زياده عدد سكانها منذ
انهاء سياسه الطفل الواحد رسميا في عام
2016 ومنذ التخلي عن هذه السياسه تحاول
السلطات تشجيع العائلات على انجاب مزيد من
الاطفال لكن محاولاتها لم تكلل بالنجاح
بسبب التاخر في سن الزواج وعدم رغبه
الازواج في الانجاب نظرا الى التكلفه
العاليه لتربيه الاطفال في المدن
والمنافسه الشرسه في سوق العمل والاسكان
لطالما كانت الصين اكبر دوله في العالم من
حيث عدد السكان ولكن من المتوقع ان تتفوق
عليها الهند قريبا اذا لم يكن ذلك قد حدث
بالفعل تشير التقديرات الى ان عدد سكان
الهند يزيد على مليار و400 مليون ويستمر
في النمو